[Musique]
nous allons vivre un changement majeur
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
la révolution des machines alors je me
suis posé une question universelle qui
nous concerne tous pourquoi avons nous
peur de l'intelligence artificielle et
bien il s'avère que je suis retourné à
mon enfance la première fois que je les
rencontre et notamment dans les films et
les romans de science-fiction de la plus
sympathique à comme r2d2 et c3po dans
star wars alliés des héros voulant
sauver la galaxie de l' empire du côté
obscur jusqu'à la plus méchante hal 9000
dans le 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
figure de la de la machine froide et
mali l'intelligence artificielle est la
cause est la raison de notre peur et
celle ci est due aux progrès
technologiques s'est dit cette dernière
décennie nous a montré comme le prouve
la loi de moore sur l'expo n'en ciel de
la capacité de calcul des machines qui
aujourd'hui pour certaines sont capables
de dépasser les 1000 milliards
d'opérations par seconde ou encore la
capacité des réseaux de neurones
complexe à traiter de grandes quantités
de données donnent lieu aujourd'hui à la
reconnaissance d'image la reconnaissance
vocale reconnaissance de texte
et qui ici n'a jamais parlé à son
smartphone dit syrie ok google ils vont
se réveiller là seulement voilà les
progrès technologiques créer des
transformations profondes dans nos
sociétés et particulièrement dans les
entreprises
alors il ya une situation dans laquelle
on n'a pas vraiment envie de voir
l'intelligence artificielle pointer le
bout de son transistor
celle ci s'est les études supérieures
longue coûteuse difficile
c'est un moment central dans la vie de
personnes est peu
par des étudiants qui sont ici et
ailleurs se sont déjà demandé et on fait
des recherches sur l'évolution des
métiers qui pour qui leur est propre de
l'évolution des métiers de leur
formation
ceux là sont pour la plupart en
transformation ça m'est personnellement
arrivé donc je sais de quoi je parle
la première fois c'était lorsque j'étais
juste après mon bac
quand j'ai décidé de me lancer dans des
études plutôt courte celle d'agent
d'accueil dans les agences bancaires et
il s'est avéré que ce métier puisse être
automatisée à plus de 90% notamment à
travers la reconnaissance vocale la
possibilité si on le souhaite de créer
un hologramme d'une personne pour 6 pour
représenter cette forme de relations ou
encore la capacité de reconnaître des
documents ont très bien je décide de me
réorienter et je choisis la formation
comptable très mauvaise idée parce que
les machines calcul mille fois mieux que
moi en fait elles sont faites pour ça
donc
eh bien je pars à nouveau je suis quand
même en colère parce que je me sens
profondément impuissance à la alors je
décide de rebondir et je prend la fuite
seulement je prends quand même le temps
de prévenir mes camarades à la manière
de cours et pauvres fous mais quand même
prenez cela en considération et je
l'espère pour vous que vous arriverez à
trouver un moyen d'atteindre la sécurité
de l'emploi
seulement voilà il y a pire que la
suppression d'emplois car aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle est
également une arme très puissante à vrai
dire vous connaissez et skynet un
terminator skynet existe oui vraiment en
fait c'est un programme de l'année ça il
permet d'identifier des présumés
terroristes au moyen orient
il a permis notamment de débusquer ben
laden et eh bien ils analysent en fait
les données de communication qui passe à
travers nos smartphones par la suite
skynet envoie des drones au thon
qui eux lancent des missiles sur ces
présumés terroristes
seulement parfois ce n'est pas
uniquement des terroristes c'est des
civils alors face à cela il ya de
nombreux problèmes géopolitiques qui
apparaissent face à une machine qui tue
par erreur des soldats ou des civils
il est normal se trouvait de tenter de
chercher qui est le responsable est le
programmeur est l'entreprise qui l'a
conçu est ce le gouvernement qui
l'utilisent
c'est pour ça que à mon sens même si
j'adore terminator je trouve le clin
d'oeil de la nsa de très très mauvais
goût et je pense que les armements les
dispositifs d'armement autonomes sont
définitivement une mauvaise idée
et ça je ne suis pas le seul à le
revendiquer les personnalités influentes
comme elon musk bill gates steve wosniak
stephen hawking
s'inquiète sincèrement des applications
controversé qui puisse en être fait
nombre de nombreux chercheurs qui ne
souhaitent pas en fait ne veulent pas
construire des armes parce que celle ci
les desservirait
lll réduirait leur image et bloquerait
les avantages sociétaux futur que
pourrait apporter l'intelligence
artificielle
il ya une lettre
ouverte qui a été signée par plus de
3700 chercheur en intelligence
artificielle et robotique ainsi que
vingt mille autres personnes
tif 2
dire définitivement les dispositifs
d'armement autonome donc je vous incite
à signer cette lettre car il ya là un
désir de rendre l'intelligence
artificielle bénéfique pour l'humanité
et non pas néfaste
d'ailleurs l'intelligence artificielle
pour réellement sauver des vies en effet
elle peut faire elle peut faire en sorte
de réduire le taux de mortalité
car dans ce monde il ya des problèmes
graves notamment le cas des maladies
aujourd'hui cette année c'est plus de
neuf millions de personnes qui vont
mourir du cancer
qui vont mourir du cancer
seulement
et c'est davantage les pays les moins
développés qui subissent ces
conséquences
car en effet pour seulement 24 % d'entre
eux ils sont équipés en matériel médical
permettant le diagnostic
non des solutions
existent notamment à travers des
recherches comme ce fut le cas à
standford des chercheurs ont donc permis
ont donc créé un algorithme capable de
détecter des cancers de la peau
maintenant prenons cette intelligence
artificielle cet algorithme couplons le
à nos drones autonome de tout à l'heure
mais cette fois ci au lieu d'envoyer des
missiles
ils sont équipés en matériel médical et
il sauve des vies
au lieu de les supprimer
je pense que la machine a un rôle à
jouer et taf est également un fidèle
allié de l'homme
je m'explique
où nous
les plus les plus à plaindre en réalité
la france et même un beau pays dans
lequel on a une sécurité au niveau de la
santé donc nous sommes pris entre entre
dans un dans une indifférence qui nous
dit d'un côté et l'intelligence
artificielle peut être maléfique
d'un autre côté un peu être bénéfique et
du coup la barrière entre la peur et la
confiance est très très minces du coup
c'est en faisant en sorte de créer de
subtiles synergie entre les capacités
cognitives humaine et la puissance des
machines que nous pouvons je le pense
faire des miracles
pensez-y d'un côté nous avons
la créativité humaine de l'autre nous
avons la puissance de calcul des
machines
nous avons la passion
elles ont la mémoire
nous sommes dotés d'intelligence
émotionnelle elles sont précises
c'est une équipe gagnante qui peut se
faire si on collabore avec elle et non
pas contre elle
en effet
les gens' des machines à je le pense
pour unique mission de maximiser nos
objectifs humains et pour cela en créant
une utilité quotidienne et pour cela
nous allons tenter de comprendre quelle
quelle utilité
elles peuvent avoir dans nos vies
se consommer notre temps car d'un côté
c'est notre ressource la plus précieuse
alors pourquoi pas faire en sorte que
l'intelligence artificielle nous fasse
gagner du temps par exemple dans le
cadre d'un rendez vous elle pourrait
prendre les sms et mail à notre place
les gérer ou encore si elle peut si elle
peut faire en sorte que les banquiers si
elle peut automatiser un banquier ou un
comptable qui sont des personnes avec
qui
personnellement ce n'est pas forcément
de relations sociales très approfondie
et qu'en plus de ça elles permettent de
me faire gagner plus d'argent qu'ils ne
feront jamais dans ce cas là je veux
bien laisser faire donc de ce constat
j'ai fait un rêve
je vous
créer une interface
de contrôle et de communication hamon
machine je voulais pouvoir apprendre à
une machine en lui écrivant ou en lui
parlant et en faire une sorte de mémoire
externe comme pourrait l'être un
smartphone ou un ordinateur personnel
aujourd'hui
la particularité
elle soit accessible et sans contrainte
aujourd'hui j'y travaille je crée je
construis des assistant intelligent qui
met qui vous propose l'information dont
vous avez besoin au moment opportun
en fait c'est à travers cette synergie
entre l'homme et la machine
hier que nous sommes déjà dans l'avenir
cette synergie existe réellement et dans
mon travail
l'intelligence artificielle permet
d'automatiser et de rendre plus
productif par exemple elle m'aide à
faire un veille en me proposant des
articles qui m'intéressent qui sont
importants dans mon domaine d'activité
alors ne vous y trompez pas
l'intelligence artificielle sera dans
tous les secteurs d'activité
pour ceux qui l'acceptent et aujourd'hui
de nombreux projets voient le jour
une nouvelle génération de start-up
émergent
alors si vous êtes intéressé par
l'aventuré
une petite forme prenez un secteur
d'activité x
ajoutez y de l'intelligence des
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
et qui sait peut-être que l'un d'entre
vous dans cette salle inventera le
service que tout le monde utilisera dans
20 ans alors continuons de rêver aux
applications futures
aujourd'hui imaginons demain alors ne
vous en privez merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]